well I do remember that okay that's not
very I don't know if it's positive
because I'm not is negative being a dick
no but it happened I was there that did
happen yeah Brian was like offering what
if he was trying to don't know because
you were poor yeah yeah people we bear
I've never met it was because you were
bragging about all your money and I
thought maybe you should put your money
where your mouth is and I paid for it
because you bragging I barely ate
anything I did I paid for it and didn't
make a den but I just thought it was
nice no no you know how be it was so
happy with yourself bro don't say all
right I know dude we ordered a lot of
food at a very nice place good wine and
good wine I don't even drink
yeah you suggested that I pay for
everyone right and I did okay okay and
the interesting thing about that is okay
it didn't make a dent right right no
right no it didn't make it didn't make a
dent right but it bothered you it's so
obnoxious I was listeners right new so
because you're bragging about the money
you make it's so obnoxious but because
it can all be taken away from you are
you laughing in a good way you see what
happens is mmm blood starts to boil yeah
blood starts to boil right starting to
see the bun I see it and I don't want to
make [ __ ] I don't want to make your
body look like your bank account which
is one low dance okay okay Brian
followed dance Cal don't start these
because I could do my shows and people
go full of dead people call me sweet
tart tart nasty do you know how viral it
should be fine in a few days do you know
I'm talking about it's so annoying
oh cool here's a hundred bucks yeah now
of course that doesn't make
hey that's not what still shouldn't be
about you making money it's not about
making money it's about me losing $100
which doesn't make a [ __ ] dude
goddamn sick with it and then I go out
and I go to pay and I was like what do I
owe and they were like you know what we
don't want to charge you we love your
work but you're come on I know I know
come on please right I know I was in
your shoes right here I was like please
let me pay something you know at least
two three grand I don't know how much it
cost but they were like whatever doesn't
make a and and then but she was like she
was like yeah you're sick with it and I
was like god it's all good just like I
knew somebody who was sick with it once
I was like who and she said a Gregory
Peck I was like Jesus I was here to do
just a couple things I guess he's gonna
do a couple of impressions the oh well
can you do I think you have a crystal
impression you just burst in here oh my
god good $2.00 my god bad geez that's so
bad is that Chris Chris dude my his hair
is longer than mine and it's true I
swear to God for a second I thought that
was Christo yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]